merci françois alors c'est une question
pour tous les deux parce que à plein de
niveaux c'est c'est extrêmement
courageuse que vous faites dans ce film
là parce que évidemment ça touche tout
le monde cette histoire on est tous
qu'on a tous vécu ça oui tous concerné
passer à l'histoire l'a donc oui
commençons par le vendre et six mois je
vous a fallu pour jouer ce rôle-là
toujours excitant d'avoir un rôle où il
ya beaucoup de choses d'un créa bas à
faire évidemment c'était
fort
impressionnant de jouer un homme tout un
bouquin abc et qui à la détermination de
son année de mettre un terme à sa vie et
qui va demander à sa fille de l'aider
mais bon il ya des frais fixes est
excitant c'est la première fois pour la
première scène quand elle rentre dans la
chambre d'hôpital qu'elle doit son père
comme ça vous avez un petit regard qui
dit énormément et là c'était comment
quand vous l'avez découvert dans cette
position là avec 7,7 figura je prends
trop en dire pour engager le pc c'etait
17 pour les acteurs formidables des
scènes de vérité et d'authenticité de 2
beaucoup de comédies
andré a pris beaucoup de plaisir à être
méchant parfois être sarcastique envoyer
chier les normes et les codes et c'est
un plaisir aussi pour l'acteur de voir
le tracteur jouer donner de l'émotion
c'est un film qui est sur l'émotion mais
qui aussi sur un pelé les surprises de
la vie et
voilà c'est pas toujours peut se marrer
aussi quoi et franchement c'est haut en
couleur quand même c'est un personnage
il est il a énormément plaisir à jouer
quand c'était rien que ça c'était un
bonheur de le voir jouer quoi vivre
entre le drame et puis la comédie des
choses drôles ces bons départs et dans
le pathos sans passer françois ozon qu'a
voulu raconter la vie telle qu'elle est
avec tous les moments différents que
doit subir tous les protagonistes de
l'histoire c'était assez d'efforts c'est
aussi un film sur le suicide assisté
c'est une question actuelle d'actualité
sous peu un succès important qu on en
parle aujourd'hui
si les matchs à temps de parler de
parler voie de communiqué de dire d'
exprimer ce qu'on ressent puisque ça on
en parlait tour des sujets car ça ne les
évite m'a donc forcément aux régions
l'otan sera obligé de parler donc
c'est ça soulage je pense alors essayé
des choses
jouer
sauzon il aborde des sujets d'importance
qu'on parle
dans la société était
je crois qu'on n'a pas fini de parler de
l'euthanasie tirage broc et de loin
qu'hier encore en sentir les problèmes
discutés encore embêter députés ont
discuté en septembre
on voit là mais
et c'est au coeur
occupation de pas mal de gens
c'est monté les marches merci infiniment
merci beaucoup et bravo pour le film